Samsung has recently released their most
expensive mainstream foam ever the
Galaxy S 20 ultra for a massive starting
price of fourteen hundred dollars and so
far it looks like this incredibly hyped
launch was a massive flop here's why
first off not that many people are
willing to spend a thousand dollars on a
smartphone let alone a huge $1,400
especially knowing that in about six
months Samson will be releasing the note
20 anyway and at that price the s20
ultra is gonna have massive expectations
and it better perform exactly how
samsung said it would and I think that's
part of why it failed this review from
Android police explains it perfectly a
$1400 phone needs to be perfect and this
one isn't at Samsung's unpacked event
they made it seem like it was the best
phone ever made by going way overboard
with the marketing with the new 108
megapixel main camera the crazy 100x
space zoom lens a 40 megapixel selfie
camera in an insane 8k video recording
feature now while all those specs sound
incredible it turned out that some of
them are just plain gimmicks and don't
just take my word for it many of the
initial reviews from reviewers who
received an S 20 altra before the actual
launch were disappointed with it the
verge complained about camera software
issues and called the 100 X zoom and 108
megapixel main camera features mostly
gimmicks they ended up calling the
regular $1,000 s 20 better than the
ultra mkbhd rated the new crazy camera
system on the s20 ultra as third place
behind the pixel for in the iPhone 11
pro he also called the new a Kei video
recording mode really really bad in
terms of autofocus performance and
mentioned a bunch of other reasons why
he'd rather stick with 4k for another
year or two and mister who's the boss is
extremely popular battery test the s20
ultra came in fourth place using the 120
Hertz mode which most buyers will
obviously be using and it actually got
worse battery life than last year's Note
10 plus and the list goes on and on with
initial reviewers being a bit
by the s20 ultra and first impressions
matter a lot to consumers looking to buy
a new phone we tested the 8k video
recording mode and we noticed that
stabilization went out the window the
overall exposure of the image became
really dark the autofocus speed was
terrible it was plagued with huge focus
hunting issues and in low to medium
light situations the iPhone 11 pros 4k
footage was actually more detailed than
the s20 ultras 8k now Samsung did admit
that the Estonian camera is having
software issues and they pledged to
improve it there's a good chance that
consumers are waiting to buy the s2000
until the software improves and with
more and more videos coming out showing
underwhelming performance for the price
some of those people will end up
changing their minds more on the whole
software update ordeal in a minute
but I want to first mention that I think
Samsung made a few mistakes that'll end
up hurting the sales of the Estonian try
one of the major features of the ultra
is 5g supporting both sub 6 and the
superfast millimeter wave 5g but they
also included the same exact support on
the cheaper $1,200 s 20 plus so that's
one less reason to go for the ultra and
those who have realized that the 108
megapixel main camera and the 100 times
space zoom features are gimmicks can
save $200 and get a regular 12 megapixel
camera which features a tried-and-true
Sony sensor instead of Samsung's own
brand new 108 megapixel sensor which is
experiencing the issues to make it even
worse both the regular s 20 and s 20
plus pack the long-awaited 120 Hertz
displays and even 8k video recording so
for a lot of people it may make sense
just to go with these cheaper models and
save a lot of cash is no wonder why the
verge said the regular s 20 was better
than the ultra another mistake I think
Samsung made was continuing to sell
their S 10 series of phones at some
pretty great discounts which are all
pretty good phones and they actually
pack headphone jacks
unlike the S 20 series and to make this
even worse all of this is happening in
the midst of the new virus that has all
but crashed the stock market this means
that consumers are
more cautious about buying a brand-new
phone let alone a phone that costs
$1,400 and this isn't just my own
speculation Samsung themselves has
blamed the poor first day sales of the
s20 line on the virus specifically
around half as much sales as last year's
as ten line sales in the first day and
looking at all the recent news in stock
market the situation doesn't seem to get
any better for the $1400 s Tony altra we
recently put out a video where we ran a
blind test between the cameras on last
year's Note 10 plus the new S 20 plus
and the s 20 ultra all running the
latest software to my surprise I chose
photos and videos from the note 10 plus
more often than the other two and so did
a lot of people in the comments section
there were quite a few people who
commented that we need to wait for the
software updates and then the S 20 ultra
is going to get much better
they said that most phones that get
released don't perform great in terms of
camera quality until a couple of updates
come out however it's been 2 weeks since
we first got our hands on it and that
magical software update is nowhere to be
found and I want to remind you guys that
when the iPhone 11 Pro was released the
cameras performed great right out of the
box and even the initial reviewers were
extremely impressed with it no waiting
around for magical software updates that
will fix the cameras now while I do
agree that Samsung will continue to
improve the cameras with updates I don't
think they'll be able to make them great
any time soon because I believe that
part of the problem is actually the
hardware itself for the new main camera
they're using their own brand new
Samsung sensor instead of the usual
reliable Sony sensor so there could be
limitations in terms of dynamic range
and focus performance as we've seen in
our camera tests we also see an issue in
close-up shots where the center is in
focus in the outer parts of the image
are all smeared this is because they
used a sensor so large that it's
incredibly hard to get the lens optics
right without having this problem the 4x
optical telephoto lens uses a very dark
F 3.5 aperture instead of the s 20
pluses F 2.0 aperture which naturally
lets in a la
more like that's why these telephoto
images turned out so bad on the ultra
compared to the more traditional note 10
and s 20 plus these are two things you
just can't fix with software and that's
part of the reason why it's been two
weeks with no updates so if you're
looking to buy the ultra I would
honestly recommend waiting for that
update to get released to see if the
camera does actually get better or not
we're actually planning to shoot a
camera test before and after the update
to see what's changed in what hasn't so
if you're interested in seeing that
click that circle above to subscribe so
you don't miss it
and check out those camera comparisons
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]